hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview but before
we get into this interview i want to
talk about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primex bt is that
you can also follow some of the best
traders in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got jordy
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
i appreciate you inviting me anthony
thanks for sure let's just start with
your background you uh run a very large
hedge fund today but
uh how did you get your career started
and then what were the steps you took
before uh before you got here
um my background started at uh at morgan
stanley
right out of college but um i always try
to give people a little bit of
perspective on just
a little further back just because it
didn't start the traditional way and i
think it kind of helps
explain how i approach things when it
comes to markets and
my father is and was a construction
worker who invented
all his own equipment so it's this
dynamic of someone who
had an engineering mind who didn't
finish high school
understood probabilities and taught me
those things
and that led to kind of a
non-traditional path to
to wall street which was really focused
on just my love of risk reward and
probabilities
and so when i went through school i
didn't particularly uh
embrace school but i made it through
for my family and then when i got the
job at morgan stanley it was in
kind of the controllers and risk
management area and i had the luxury of
being able to
build some risk systems uh
as my first job and that transition into
me moving into the derivative world and
so derivatives is really about
probabilities and
and outcomes and so i uh i ended up in a
place where i think my father kind of
taught me how to think about things and
it was a good place for me to be and
then
through luck and circumstance i ended up
in emerging markets for
almost all of the 90s which was a great
place again to be because you not only
had to deal with risk reward but you had
to deal with
uh volatility of volatility and
uncertain outcomes and so you really had
to focus on the tales of the
distribution
and i think that's become more important
today even in the developed world where
maybe in the 90s that developed worlds
with a stable place
i think over the course of the last 10
years really since the great financial
crisis
we've seen a shift and so i think my
background just in terms of derivatives
emerging markets
believing that not only do tales occur
more than
the statistics would argue but also that
when they do occur
if you're in a position beforehand to
not get emotional those are the greatest
opportunities to be involved in
and unlike past crisis that have
occurred in the united states where they
tend to
fall and then take a long time to
recover we seem to be in this boom bust
cycle where
things happen much at a much faster pace
and i think that matches up with the
technology
side so that's a little bit of the
background how it all feeds in
yeah talk a little bit about the
emerging markets obviously um
as we kind of watch what's happening in
the united states today i think there's
a lot of people who point to
you know certain emerging markets and
say hey we've seen this kind of play out
before
and they try to use emerging markets as
kind of evidence whether it's
for or against any specific kind of
topic but
it seems like emerging markets just
serve right now
as kind of a uh historical example in
some cases and so
uh maybe just unpack a little bit more
about what that experience in the
emerging markets was and kind of what
some of your takeaways were as you
spent so much time there yeah it's a
good question
um so i lived in brazil from
from 97 to 99 and there were a bunch of
things i learned there i think it was
important for anyone
who lives in the you know the safety of
the united states to get a chance to
live
in countries where there's a lot more
risk and it opens up your eyes to
some of the reasons for it from a macro
basis is where all my macro
kind of background began and i would say
emerging markets compared to where they
were in the 90s
are very similar in some ways and
extremely different
in kind of where they are both from an
interest rate inflation perspective
and if you think about brazil as an
example
when i had my first portuguese lesson i
remember we spent almost the entire time
when we got to the history of brazil
almost all of it was on the currencies
just because they had had so many in
such a short amount of time
but the recognition for me was i'm in a
completely different place than than the
united states and
the financial situation for the country
having just come out of hyperinflation
uh left a residue of people waiting
for when the next time it'll happen when
i moved to the country i remember the
first example this was they were giving
you the things you needed to buy
to fill out your apartment and one of
the three
uh things on the list one of the top
three was a meat
freezer and i asked the person why i
need a meat freezer and they said well
to protect you against inflation so
since we're going to talk about probably
inflation later on
that was a thought process that you just
don't know what the future is going to
look like
and now we've got rates at insanely low
levels relative to where they were when
i was there
inflation has been under much better
control
the biggest change right now for me and
where emerging markets have
a sweet spot in terms of where i think
people should view them not where they
are
right now during covid but where they
will be five years from now
is this whole concept of leapfrogging
and they get the benefit of not having
invested a tremendous amount of
technology
they have people that um are being
educated more so than ever
on youtube or taking advantage of of
something they didn't have when i was
there which is there were shortages of
teachers
inside the country and now because a
million people can go to class online
these countries are going to benefit
significantly in the next five to 10
years from having a lot of hungry people
that have been very poor that are able
to learn online
uh which they never were able to do and
those changes take time to pass through
but i would say the biggest difference
is that technology there the leap
frogging is going to be a major story
over the next five years
and i'm sure with your knowledge on the
crypto side you know brazil
argentina all of these countries are
heavily involved on the crypto side
and i think a lot of that has to do with
the governments in the way that they've
not trusted them in the past so it's
giving them a strength and a populist
movement in those countries
that again takes a long time to
represent itself in the capital markets
but it's one of the places that i have a
very
uh very strong opinion of going forward
that they will be the
a big uh they will benefit a lot from
what's happening at post coven
absolutely before we get into kind of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies i want to
talk
just about the macro economy um and i
know you've obviously been paying a lot
of attention to this uh we're about nine
ten months
from when i would say really the the
macro economy reaction to covid started
uh so in the united states once we sort
of shut down in kind of march of 2020
the federal reserve and elected
officials stepped in they intervened to
the markets they
printed now you know four plus trillion
dollars and uh and really kind of
uh in a very historic way we've seen
both positive and negative right so kind
of historic levels
unemployment historic levels of
quantitative easing uh historic kind of
emergency rate cuts down to zero just
so many different things that have
happened that just hadn't happened
before
what's your evaluation of kind of what's
happened over the last nine or ten
months and then like where we stand
today from a macro
uh kind of evaluation
one of the things i think to say right
off the bat and
um you know i've i've written well i've
done webinars for most the last year but
since
really when the printing started and
that's where we have to kind of start
the conversation i i think
one of the problems is um the concept of
of the dollars
um there's there's a different side to
dollars and
i'll just i'll give you an idea if you
have
a hundred thousand dollars saved up and
fifty thousand of it is
is in in your house meaning you have
fifty thousand dollars of net worth in
your house and you have twenty five
thousand dollars
in in in art and then you have twenty
five thousand dollars in the bank
if you had a hundred thousand dollars in
the bank you obviously can immediately
go out and spend a hundred thousand the
other ones you have to go through a
bunch of
inertia to get the money to be able to
go spend and the reason i bring that up
is that's the way i viewed the
difference
in march and april of this year and
continued now is that
it's not just four trillion dollars it
is the fact that we are handing
checks to people and this is a major
difference than what had happened to
where
during a recession of this magnitude
where the entire world was shut down
personal income could grow in the united
states and that's what happened last
year never happened before so if you go
back to the great financial crisis it
took a long time for personal income to
get back up to the levels that it was
before the crisis and that makes sense
people are out of work until everyone
gets their job back you don't have your
income back up but in this case
we magically found a way and i say
magically because it hadn't been done
before
and it's continuing we're doing more
stimulus checks now and so
the first part is for people when they
think about last year
in hindsight i don't think enough people
grasped on the fact that we were handing
people money
and that meant it would be spent the
second thing was because we shut
everything down
everyone in the world has excess
expenses and
nothing makes you realize you've been
overspending on things you don't need to
spend on
meaning a restaurant a bottle of wine
anything is a lot more expensive if you
go out and get it than if you stay at
home and you order it in
everyone saved a lot of money so the
savings rate exploded
and it's still high and we're about to
give people more checks so
you had this unique event around the
globe where people's income was being
made up for them while they were home
and their expenses went down
and so the macro economy coming out of
this as far as i'm concerned has changed
forever because of
covid we had an election that coincided
with it um
the election is going to lead in some
form to some redistribution of
of wealth or at least that's the path
that it seems to be going
um and that's very different than what
we've seen so
some people call it modern monetary
theory i don't want to label it because
i think the reality is just like when
they change
um rules in sports uh and
and want to get more points on the board
which every
every sports team has done to keep them
interactive i think between what's
happening in reddit and the amount of
money splashing around the system
we've just increased the speed of this
game dramatically
and that means you have to adapt
significantly in the macro economy and i
think
you can't use history as a gauge for
what's happening right now because i
think the
amount of dollars that are sitting in
the system is dramatic and i think the
change is happening at the political
level
in terms of the redistribution are
probably far greater than we realize and
they lead to
uh a drastic change that i think we're
seeing in all aspects of the global
economy
so two questions off of that the first
is in terms of uh the importance of
actually handing money you talked a
little bit about
kind of personal income levels and the
savings rate are there any other
kind of ramifications from that activity
of actually giving money directly to
people versus maybe stuff they get
somewhere else in the economy
there's a lot of there's a lot of
differences that happen when you when
you hand out money i don't think we've
seen
um the full impact and what i mean by
that is
we're continuing to give people money
and remember covet is still going on
it's just not happening we're not
shutting down everything in the system
and people have gotten used to being at
home
but my strongest belief for the next six
months is people are underestimating
the partying that is going to go on once
the northern part of the of this
hemisphere gets warm
there are more people out in manhattan
now
far more than there were at any time
during i would say march to june of last
year yet the cases were
much higher this time so people have
just come to live with it
so the recency bias over being worried
about it is is
is down and yet their pockets are full
of cash which they will spend
this is obviously not everyone but
they're the same when you go across
economy is driven by
the amount of dollars that's sitting in
the system it's not about any one group
or any any one person that's out of work
so when i talk about this the economy is
kind of it puts everyone together and i
just think the amount of dollars that
people are sitting on is going to be
spent in a very big way it has clearly
helped um
housing so you've had this move away
from
uh from new york and it involves a lot
of things
with millennials that were way before
way behind the baby boomers and the gen
xers in terms of their
home ownership and once nothing drives
human beings more to
doing things first than running away
from a disease which they can't see but
then secondly as
they see other people making money on
their house it leads to more people
wanting to own houses
because why pay rent when you can put it
into an asset that's going up at 15
a year and we're getting to levels in
terms of house appreciation that rival
back
you know before really before the great
financial crisis so i think that's going
to continue
and when you buy things outside the
house it means you're probably going to
go buy cars at the same time we ended up
with
rates at historically low levels so
it's a very combustible situation so
it's not just the money printing it's
the low rates that are associated with
the two and the fact that we're going to
have this grand reopening
in about three months that uh regardless
i think of where where cobit is in the
u.s
i think people have already proven that
they're ready to spend money it's just a
reflection of getting through the winter
time at this point
yeah i think that you're you're dead-on
on a lot of that you mentioned kind of
uh
changes to the macro environment now
that there's so much money sloshing
around
uh you mentioned reddit and a couple of
other aspects to it what are some of
those main changes that you are paying
attention to right not so much just the
kind of simple hey there's more spending
or uh housing had kind of a short-term
uh benefit but what do you think of the
long-term changes the macro economy are
going to be
well let's go back to what happened
a great financial crisis because the the
world changed after that as well and i
think we all know
um you know the winners and losers
so post-grade financial crisis uh
we've seen six companies in the united
states of america
facebook apple amazon google tesla
microsoft and some other one i guess i'm
forgetting
their total market cap as of today is
8.3 trillion dollars
the growth we've seen and the dominance
by six companies
to be that big those six companies the s
p
1500 which is a broad base index in the
united states
that sum of market cap for the top six
names out of the 1500
it's greater than the bottom 86
so you've had the number one theme
coming out of that is that software has
gobbled up everything amazon dominated
malls and you had all of this thing that
happened
post that time so the question is what
will be the themes coming out of this
one so when i talk about the fact that
there's a redistribution of wealth going
on when you hear things about wealth
taxes well wealth taxes impact
people that own a lot of stocks and
those six companies if you go through
a lot of the owners and i won't pick out
their names but they have lots of money
and so if you put a wealth tax it's not
good for those stocks at the same time
we're seeing the reddit community
rev up and have an impact and the impact
is having on
the bottom name so i just gave you a
stat on the s p 1500 for the last uh
or yeah for the market cap so far this
year i went through this today
um the s p 1500 is up about three
percent
there's over 120 names in the s p 1500
that are already up this year over 25
there are zero that are down 25
or more the names out of the 120 plus
that are up
only eight of them have a market cap of
over 10 billion dollars
so what you're left with is the reddit
community is having an impact on smaller
securities like they did with gamestop
and some of the ones that got all the
attention last week they can't move
amazon around it's too big
but they can certainly move around the
smaller groups and i think that is going
to continue and that's a change so um
one of the reasons is because the
millennials took over the baby boomers
as the biggest
group or demographic in the united
states it's not just that fact but
i think everyone knows that every day
and if they don't know there's about 5
000 baby boomers who die every day
the wealth transfer that's expected to
occur over the next 30 years is
the numbers i've read are up to 70
trillion dollars
but there is money being transferred
every day from
a passive investing group that is older
into a group that has
shown to be a little bit more
comfortable with single names and
getting involved in the market and
probably is more of a gaming community
and i think that dynamic has shifted the
stock market so
those things are kind of impacting the
market where it flips into the macro
economy
and starts to get into inflation which
is what i've spent a lot of my time
writing
we have had three events occur that i
think are
really important for people to think
about one is the trade war that went on
with china which is still having
repercussions
um we will never have the relationship
that we had with china so the divorce
has occurred
and when you build all of your your
uh kind of your inputs in both labor
and kind of getting cheaper goods over
there and now you're
saying you have to redeploy the supply
chains all around the globe that has an
input
on costs it just does secondly you had
the printing that went on an enormous
amount of money to offset the slowdown
and then for covid covet is impacting
the supply side because where it does
have a
massive impact is in social distancing
and so most of the supply side has some
form of people being close together
and you've seen that whether it's been
through meat companies having to shut
down
all of these different places where you
shove a lot of people into a short term
has created a situation where there's
going to be supply shortages for the
rest of this year until we can catch up
you just can't
you can't get it going fast enough with
code that's still out there and in
particular when it's in a lot of the
emerging markets worse than it is in the
developed markets you end up with this
whole situation so the demand side keeps
moving fast but the supply side has been
impacted both by the trade war
and and uh the covid situation so i
think people are underestimating the
inflation
side uh i can't think of a more
combustible situation than all of those
happening at the same time
so when people refute inflation or they
say it's not going to come
i think the mistake will be for people
that we haven't had enough investment
on the input cost side of commodities
over the last 10 years
primarily because of again esg and the
movements that it's had in terms of
forcing people to
focus on climate change the problem is
we still drive mainly cars that are
fossil fuel until that changes
if you under-invest in that area you end
up with another input cost inflation
side so
if inflation doesn't happen i'm going to
be shocked but all of the paths say that
the number one thing coming out of this
crisis that will surprise people
is is inflation and when you think
through that
uh inflation can mean a whole bunch of
different things
uh both in severity and also where it
shows up talk through a little bit of
just
what is your expectation fully
understanding is a you know complex
system
literally the facts change on a
day-to-day basis but just kind of
as we stand right now where do you
expect the inflation to show up
and how severe will it be you know it's
that's it's the first time someone's
asked the question like that
it is the way it should always be with
inflation
in fact someone asked me the question on
inflation i said you know when you
listen to the recaps of
in the morning of what happened in
sports the night before and they try to
find different words to define the
outcome and they'll go
and the cavaliers crushed the lakers and
there was a
the knicks blew out or they squeaked by
it's always somewhere well that's what
inflation is inflation at the end of the
day
has no true definition so what a big
number is
uh it i just don't understand what it
really means so the way that i've kind
of said this is
core inflation in the united states the
one that the fed predominantly uses
which is the pce core deflator
has really not migrated far away from
the one and a half to two and a quarter
percent range for basically my entire
career in this industry
um very seldomly you find a more stable
thing than the pce core and i think that
has everything to do with
the technological influences that have
been going on since really the personal
home computer entered it and we started
going through it and i am a deflationist
at heart i believe
technology will continue to keep
inflation in check
but when you're defining inflation i do
think we're going to have commodity
inflation
um i do think we're gonna have uh
problems with
uh restaurants and their restaurants are
gonna pass through expenses
uh there's gonna be supply shortages for
airline seats for hotel rooms once this
thing opens and everyone tries to travel
at the same time
i don't know how we're gonna ramp up the
supply that quickly and hire all the
people that we laid off when they're
getting paid to stay at home it's just
not going to be the simple thing to get
through it so in the short term until we
get through that i think there's going
to be inflation for at least the next 18
months
my guess is that people will start to
learn the difference between headline
inflation and
and pce core core inflation will have
trouble going up too much i do think
it'll get up to probably the highest
levels we've seen
in some time but my guess is you know
three percent would be the highest that
we could see on that and then headline
inflation i think we will see five and a
half to six percent
uh by the time we get through the end of
the summer i think that's going to be
the peak of this
but then at that point as has been the
case with silicon valley any place where
there's
any kind of margins in anything there
will be people coming with technology to
drive those margins back down
and within three years four years my
guess is that we will find a way to to
move
inflation back down to where it
traditionally has been
yeah i think it's a very rational way to
look at it and probably a pretty likely
scenario
uh let's talk about kind of the solution
so obviously the macro environment is
going to kind of do what the macro
environment does it'll kind of ebb and
flow and eventually
probably return back you know towards
the mean um
when you think of what investors can do
there's a whole bunch of different
theories out there so some theories
would be
you know stick to precious metals real
estate uh bitcoin
uh you know many others how do you just
think about portfolios and kind of
capital flows and
if people do buy into the inflation
narrative uh what should they be doing
or how are you thinking about it
well let's start with with an important
dynamic just to start off which is
um there's very few bonds existing on on
the planet that are yielding more than
two percent
and the bulk of them from the last
chance i saw
were chinese bonds predominantly because
that's the size
they're just so large but the rest of
the world europe japan and the us
were yielding basically under two
percent and in a lot of cases uh
it's still negative yields the reason
that's an important starting point is
because bonds have historically been an
asset that we've all learned is
investable and it's no longer investable
without taking significant
risks of mark to market i don't think
that rates are going to really move
higher at any time soon and
in fact if there's one place where i
differ
with most strategists and most people i
talk to is the assumption that if we get
inflation in the u.s
and that's one thing i want to emphasize
when i'm talking about inflation i'm
really
i think this is going to be very very
specific and localized to the united
states
we'll obviously see it in some other
places but i think the biggest story
will be
the united states having inflation
because we've printed the most money
we've given the most in checks to people
and we have a consumer-based economy
which
loves to spend money and we have this
problem with china where we're
literally at a trade war with them so i
think the combination of that will lead
to a localized situation of the us and
the problem is for bonds bonds are a
global asset
so the u.s yields are positive which is
different than japan and europe so
it makes it very difficult for people
not to buy us bonds and so when you end
up in that situation the first thing you
have to think about
is where bond yields are going to be and
that forces people out on the risk curve
so
for stocks um the big theme for me again
is is what i started to say which is
we've had a
a a market driven by very few names
creating the performance and i think
this is going to be much more geared
towards the smaller cap and micro-cap
securities
partly because of like i said on the buy
side these community of people that love
buying these securities
second thing is that we've beaten these
down a lot of them are in the financial
space the energy space the material
space
places that have been hurt for the last
10 years where i think there's a
resurgence
but then one of the things that happened
last week that definitely
impacts the way you know directly your
question portfolios in the way that we
think about things
there was you know a when saturday night
live is talking about gamestop
and joking about it you know you've
reached a point that something big
happened in the marketplace that will
leave an impact
and i think the impact it's going to
mean for people who short securities on
the institutional side is that they're
going to avoid these micro cap or
you know smaller than 10 billion dollar
names um and so that kind of creates a
lift to those as well and so i think for
the next at least couple years it's
going to be about small caps and micro
caps
a lot of securities will double that's
not that's not surprising coming out of
a recession like this
but i think people are going to look
there more for for alpha
in terms of themes aside from kind of
the rise of the small caps
i'm big into believing that one thing
kova did was
through these vaccines is open up the
next few years and thinking about
leaving kind of software for
corporations and for
home use and now we're going to be
getting into software for the human body
and it'll lead to longevity and some
things that i think
we're already headed in that direction
but i think the amount of capital both
from the government and the private side
that went into this area
and using covet as a way to learn more
about the way the immune system works
towards fighting off diseases will open
up an enormous amount of places in the
biotech side but really
geared towards longevity i'm very
focused on 3d printing at this point
because
with this trade war you're having being
forced to be more
localized and so there should be massive
investments in 3d printing
and so i think you're going to start to
see a lot of those companies and some of
those have been beaten down and are
micro-cap stocks some of them are up big
this year
uh so those would be kind of the the
themes that i think coming out of here
and then for the crypto side
i do think the world is changing and i'm
just gonna you know i'm gonna kind of
give you in my conversations
with with this uh bitcoin
is quickly becoming a an emerging store
of value so the debate between gold and
bitcoin i really have no interest in
other than you know people below the age
of 50
dominate bitcoin and people above the
age of 50 dominate gold
i don't want to be in that trade the
other way i mean i'll take the bitcoin
over gold side
because of the generational wealth
transfer that i mentioned i don't even
know how people argue this i
it just doesn't make any sense so i'm
not saying it replaces it but i'm saying
anyone that owns gold should have a
percentage of what they own gold for and
store value
in bitcoin as well uh bitcoin is also
it's part of a technology ecosystem
which you can't ignore
it it is a better medium of exchange
than gold it's
i've already seen it in coffee shops and
stuff on the west coast i've never seen
gold
uh accepted in coffee shops so as a
medium of exchange
uh as a technology and just as an
emerging one if you believe in
decentralized finance if you believe in
any of these
parts of the ecosystem uh regarding the
blockchain i think
bitcoin has become the dominant force in
it and i really do believe from an asset
inflation perspective if you believe the
governments have now figured a tool
where elected officials are now directly
pumping money into the system
bitcoin is just going to benefit because
it doesn't have a large size
at this point and i see it becoming an
acid every day from real institutional
people so
some themes some stuff on the future got
it and so when you think through
um kind of creating a portfolio you
mentioned a little bit like taking a
percentage of what you would allocate to
gold putting it in bitcoin
how do you think about some of the um
kind of other elements right so
as a hedge fund manager uh you've got to
balance between what i'll call like the
old world and the new world not
necessarily because the old world is bad
but just like
you can go buy a stock you can go buy a
bunch of commodities you can buy
some crypto assets like how do you just
think about where you spend your time so
maybe not so much like moving capital
but are you spending
50 of your time in in kind of the legacy
world 50 in the new world is it
75 25 just you know and i use time
almost as a proxy for
uh interest and kind of like where you
see
uh the world moving how does that break
down for you
it's a good question let me answer it
this way um because i'm in a i'm in
i'm in a unique position as i mentioned
my first my first
job at morgan stanley involved creating
technology to
to deal with risk management on options
traders
and exotic options and so from a
business perspective the first thing
that i think about where i spend a lot
of the time is infusing the firm with
technology that is specifically meant to
help me make better decisions so i'm a
moneyball freak i believe
um you cannot make decisions without a
combination of intuition and experience
combined with analytics
um and you have to measure biases to
to be able to do that so a lot of people
particularly running companies i think
in this day if they're not using
technology they're leveraging too much
experience and that experience assumes
that the data you have in the past is
representative of what the future is
going to look like and for any business
to be successful you have to make sure
that you're making decisions based on
some kind of trends that are going on so
we use a lot of technology and the
people that over the years have kind of
ended up being the drivers of the
business i will say they tend to be
younger
they tend to have different backgrounds
from each other so that we're getting a
a lot of different opinions on on where
things should be um so the first thing
is kind of making sure that the
the firm is using technology that the
people have
differences and then the people that are
managing money for us
more directly those those people i
mentioned that's kind of the business
side the people that are managing the
money
we've tried to give them technology to
help them understand their biases
so you know i think i mentioned to you
before we started to speak just briefly
that i i think of our firm as combining
um an approach which uses poker to kind
of figure out behavioral decision making
and try to make sure the people that we
have
fit the macro environment that we're
going to be in um
and where that fits in is through
turnover so turnover of a portfolio
we're not a long-term investment
place so we try to make um most of our
returns based on
dispersion in the marketplace and
dispersion is driven a lot by
the volatility in the market but also
kind of the velocity of change that's
happening and so volavol is really
important to us and so
not a lot of people are that comfortable
in a fast game like that
and so if we believe that's what the
environment is going to look like we
want to make sure that the people that
we have managing money for us
are are capable of transacting at
as fast a volume as the market would be
if you just sit in something that's not
what we do for a living we actually want
to
take advantage of things like last week
be able to provide liquidity into those
situations if we don't think they're
going to continue
i did a webinar last week where i talked
about the fact that
it wasn't systemic to me and that it was
an isolated event to
the way some people manage money we take
a different approach to managing money
we do not have concentration
we have diversity sorry diversification
and the fact that we have a lot of
securities in the portfolio and so
we're really trying to use the
technology to help identify through a
scoring system of the way people are
able to construct a neutral portfolio
but then also
uh the behavioral analysis on the alpha
that they create and how much that
turnover
is luck and how much of it is skill yeah
and it's really fascinating to kind of
uh think through the diversification and
then not only to diversify across
securities in the public market but then
you can diversify across kind of all
asset classes different markets and
you can really layer kind of a couple of
different things in there um before we
go to other rapid fire questions to
finish up
i want to ask one question which uh i'm
always fascinated by
especially people with macro backgrounds
what's been the most surprising thing
the thing you least expected that
happened
over the last kind of nine to 12 months
all right i i'm honestly gonna answer
this
with something that is you could have
said the last nine or ten days
so so i uh i grew up in emerging markets
which means
those tales are always going to happen
so i don't get fixated on the tails
but i do ask myself the question every
day what would
hurt market participants the most and
i'm specifically
in my world of just the hedge fund
community which which i
i know fairly well and i've spent a lot
of time with
i never would have expected what
happened last week and i'm not going to
go through all the details but
to see gamestop go up as much as it did
and to hurt
funds to the degree that it did i never
thought you would see something where
the market was unchanged and we would
have those kinds of losses
in established funds with with a lot of
assets
as much as kovid was a shock we all knew
that a pandemic was part of the
distribution of outcomes we may not have
envisioned it shutting down the entire
world but if you go back and look at all
the documentaries done over the last 10
years they pretty much called what would
happen um if there was a pandemic
meaning we'd have to shut everything
down and people wouldn't be able to go
and
everything that they said would happen
did happen and went on so that's why i'm
going to lean towards the fact that i
never would have expected what went on
last week and i think it has huge
implications as i said for the hedge
fund community in the way that they
manage
the way they manage money because i
don't think people are going to be
comfortable on the short side and it's
going to change
the way some funds uh manage their
business and these have been some of the
more successful ones at least over the
the last four years so
honestly that i'm still trying to figure
out because it never was in any of the
distributions i had as a potential
and a pandemic was so what is
the thing that you're doing differently
now after that's happened is there
anything
um i was on a call today and and
um in our morning meeting which we have
every day i highlighted to our teams
that uh they really need to be wary of
uh
any short positions they have on any of
these these micro cap securities and if
they
like securities that are on the smaller
side i think this is the beginning of a
long term trend
i i mean i could take you through a
bunch of of data
but the reality is as i said about the
fact that there's out of the 120 plus
that are up over 25 percent this year
um only eight of them have a market cap
of greater than 10 billion i mean that's
that's an
it's an insane statistic when given in
the past years it's been the mega cap
stocks and the bigger cap softwares
that have dominated even a company like
zoom i forget where they started last
year but at one point zoom was the same
size as exxon mobil
you know you you had a change last year
where big cap tech
software names were were going so i
think it's mainly the thing we're
talking about the most internally is
is this situation with with the small
caps and then i'll just reiterate it
again which is
i think the inflation side coming out of
this without covet i don't think we
would have had
there's no way we would have had as big
an inflation because you needed that
um that printing of money the stimulus
checks being handed to people
along with people being shut in their
house saving money by not spending
and then at the flip side having this
trade war that was existing and coveted
preventing the supply side
the shortages are going to be much
bigger than people realize and it's
going to have a short-term
inflation component and everyone has a
recency bias that whatever has been
happening is going to continue to happen
and that's why i think the peak panic or
the peak conversation inflation will
happen by uh by august of this year
yeah it's a it's a very unique view of
the world but i like it it
seems to make a lot of sense to me uh i
was asking the same three questions
before i wrap up and you get to ask me
when to finish us
uh the first is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
uh the art of learning by josh waitskin
i included in the paper i wrote at the
end of the year but
i think i've always been someone
interested in the brain and the way
people
think once i started to meditate i think
i started to appreciate
the powers of the brain a little bit
more in terms of what
what's important about being calm that
you make your worst decisions when
you're
when you're emotional but i think what
josh was able to do
was just show that if you really want to
be great at anything
um there is an element that gets into
with the preparation and really the the
focusing on your brain at
very small points and being able to slow
down everything
and so i think after that book i changed
a lot of things that i probably
did as both a manager but as a portfolio
manager
my cooking got better my skiing got
better
my golf got better a whole bunch of
things that i think i incorporated those
those those little elements that he
brought in but also i think for
all of us we're trying to you want to
constant pursuit of happiness and i
think
that book uh led me to ways that i can
be
more happy in life too yeah that's a
great answer
uh second question is a little bit more
personal it's brought to you by our
friends over at eat sleep they've got a
thermoregulation bed that basically
makes it super cold
i used to be one of these guys who
didn't sleep at all uh and now i'm like
a religious eight-hour sleeper
what's your sleep schedule are you five
six hours are you eight or nine hours
how do you think about that
uh because i have both an aura ring
and a uh a watch that measures my sleep
i have been consistently six and a half
hours for pretty much the last
uh 18 months since i had all of the
technology um
i i definitely care more about my
quality of sleep and that's where i was
trying to get the
stuff to go through it i i will say this
the one thing i learned
the easiest way to for me to have a good
sleep is to make sure that i'm asleep by
10 o'clock
so you know i heard a l i read a lot
from people on sleeping and that was my
one little thing was
if i consistently went to sleep right
around the same time
that was when i had the best sleep
scores even if i didn't get the right
amount of sleep that people would go but
six and a half is my uh
is my my normal sleep pattern i'm
jealous if you uh if you're well rested
after six and a half you're
you're saving 90 minutes that the rest
of us
uh last question is a little bit more
fun uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i'm 100 believer
i am i'm the same way now the big
question is are you a believer in that
they exist somewhere out there maybe we
never come in contact or are you a
believer in that uh
they've come to earth and no one's
telling us
i've watched enough enough documentaries
to know that
anything is possible and like i said at
the beginning when it gets into
distributions
the one thing i'm really uh i'm really
good at is
uh i and every single thing that i make
an answer to
i know there's a good chance that
whatever answer i say is wrong
and so if you go through life that way
if it's anywhere in the 30 to 60
range i'm indifferent it's just art to
me it's a flip of a coin i don't care
it's when we get into the tales where
like if i say a hundred percent which i
did absolutes are not my game in in
distribution but i'm a hundred percent
certain
uh that we are not the only creatures in
in
in in the galaxies around us that exist
so
there definitely is a high probability
that
someone's come down here to investigate
what's going on
i love it i love it you can ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
what's each day what's the most
important thing that you try to do
each day uh this has changed
um so pre pandemic who knows what i
would have said uh now
basically i go for a walk every day and
even if it's just a 20 30 minute walk or
sometimes you know if i got a couple
calls back to back i'll go and i'll walk
for two hours
uh but just getting outside and uh and
trying to get a walk in
um i don't know if it's just the you
know kind of science behind just
literally walking and
what it does to your brain and your
ability to think uh or what it is but uh
that's been something that's just kind
of been a routine that i make sure that
i do every day and
uh seems to uh to be pretty effective so
i keep doing it
great so jordan thank you so much for
taking the time to do this where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or find more about some of the work
you're doing white papers
all of that yeah we have a website it's
uh
[Music]
g-y-s-g-w-e-i-s-s dot com
um everything all the content that i do
is
on an insights tab um i write papers
about every
quarter last year was a little different
but then
if you're interested in just what's
happening in the market i do webinars
they're 15 minutes they're meant to be
very fast with a lot of information you
can pause them and go back but
that's the way i kind of get my stuff
out to the people that are both our
investors but also the people i talk to
on a regular basis so that's where you
can find everything
i love uh the 15-minute webinar that is
a uh
that's a really uh powerful thing so
listen thank you so much for taking the
time to do this
uh i really enjoyed it i hope people
learned a lot i'll do it again in the
future
anthony looking forward to it anytime
something comes up give me a ring happy
happy to jump on